ladies and gentlemen we are now catching up caught
up with superman lois episode three of season two
hey thanks for being patient with us and so yeah
i think just because of the way our shooting
schedule and editing schedule has been i think for
just safe measure i'm gonna say superman and lois
will consistently be going up on thursday mornings
that just seems like the smartest bet on our end
at this current moment in time uh so yeah that's
uh that will be our upload schedule for that
we good all right hit that like button that would
mean a lot subscribe click that notification bell
you'll notify when our reaction for that is
up of course and also full length watch as
long as we sing it with a time code for snl or
over at our patreon page big thanks to all who
become superjects your support means more
than you know and also the boys at prepper
you are the uh jordan and jonathan of our channel
you're both super though in nri you guys are great
i'll call my dad see if he can get us
credentials you don't think a surprise
visit from lois lane might raise
a few questions it would but not
one from me no helping us figure out what
was causing the earthquake i want from you
you promised now john i know but is there
anyone else you can go through right now
i love your wife clark i'll do anything for
lois you need to stop obsessing over timmy
it's not like healthy really coming from the guy
that was up all night what looking at pictures
of his own girl again that's a different story
man i want her to not have kissed someone else
care for a girl's opinion oh just that
she hated keeping that secret from you
which i mean maybe you can sympathize with you
know the whole half alien son of superman thing
i mean that's a completely different kind of
secret oh yeah it's several magnitudes bigger
she's not wrong yeah dude if you want to be honest
with her about your powers one day would you want
her to be cool about it or would you want her to
react how you are right now he didn't cheat on her
it's a personal line for everybody they're
extremely excited about the fact that there
is a woman running for mater that's true
what culture who knows what it's like to
feel unsure of yourself who knows
what it's like to feel incomplete
she looks so familiar who is this
it's really bothering me come on
i i just think it's time to be
honest and tell her you know
everything you mean about having
powers yeah like all of it no
do you realize if she told just one person
our entire family would be compromised yeah
but she wouldn't do that or she could become
the target of someone in the future who wanted
to know my identity is that what you want
oh what if i want to marry sarah i'm 15
jordan so so get in the car i i want to marry
her dad you don't know that yes i do no you don't
he used the voice that kind of scared of the
[ __ ] yeah yeah i know it's like a possession
movie just that of course john ryan they're
like always you this day would come yeah
no wait that's not living here i stockpiled sam's
old kryptonite weapons just for this occasion
that kiss meant nothing i want to be
with you i i love you it's not about you
then what's it about no i don't
know where we go from here
it's not you it's me i have to decide if i'm
gonna marry you or not only then can we date
he took some stuff at deuce or slavin's lake
house party a few weeks ago i didn't think
it was a big deal what it made him like
stronger i guess so i don't know but
it's not even like a real drug it's like some
crystal crap that only grows in small village
why didn't you tell me this
earlier i wish i didn't tell
you now you're already freaking out i'm not oh
finally jonathan's powers arise this blows
candace's head off building a sound economy
based on regional industry and agriculture and
using this rare gift we have to reinvest in us and
like kyle said i'm a woman but weren't you the one
recruiting people for the man who almost destroyed
this town no one knew who morgan edge really was
chuck right another thing you weren't aware of huh
that gonna be your answer when everything
you're preaching now doesn't come to pass
we're supposed to vote for her over george dean
when she can't even answer a simple question
this podcast is having some mystery guest on
who's just gonna lie and say whatever alston wants
your sister know about this she has to she
probably knows who the podcast is working with
they were all in that group at the same time
oh my god is her sister the guest her sister
it's got to be everything i discovered ali and
lucy were doing everything i wrote in my piece
and you still can't pick a side you didn't read
it they do don't bother talking to lucy for me
i will do this without your help like always
she's by far the best actor on this show
in every regard she really is some of those
skills might rub off on you eventually
yeah so you can go for the drugs you've been
taking too you're gonna go knock the gains on
me now whatever man oh yeah of course cause it's
your girl who's the one who's hooking me up what
bad idea
he's going to blast you
i thought clark was coaching today oh jesus
oh god he got knocked down or is he faking
it i think he's just covering really well
you don't just lash out at people like that
okay well i should have been the one out there
jonathan get out of here yeah doubt
oh my god this is so scary
dad dad we need to go home now
dad we need an exorcism because like i gotta
let this out that's so scary jesus christ
what happened to your hands that's
my heat vision i i couldn't stop it
wow rage aholic strikes again this was different
dude this is a national security situation no it
is a family situation anything kryptonian that can
affect clark can also affect the boys and besides
until we hear back from john henry we don't even
know if that's what it is wait why do you need to
hear back from my dad forgot you were living here
you really gotta pay attention to who's around i
don't know if my dad ever yelled at me like that
this thing uh it feels like the
end of the world's coming up
not the time to go all doomsday on me they
keep saying god this has to be a misleading
my bloody kryptonite oh god i think
you're right taste it son of a [ __ ]
it's that nationwide does somebody set off
explosives yeah you knew that was coming they did
so just women taking control woke culture
in my superman i don't know dad i love her
i don't think that's ever gonna change if
any year from now you still feel the same
way then maybe you and i can have a different
conversation really really in the meantime i
may have something to help show sarah that
she still care season three sarah finds out
green is good on the superman world i just
wanted you to know i read your article
a lot of grammatical errors i have some revisions
ali alston is a bad egg and your sister never
should have gotten involved with her which is
exactly what i told lucy when i called her
what'd you say most of it i'm not gonna repeat
but she did agree to meet with
you don't uh scare her away
lucy isn't strong like you she needs a delicate
touch maybe she's stronger than you know xk
everyone's juicing i'm trying to be this perfect
person that everyone wants and it feels really
fake i have an idea oh yeah come on hurry
up oh i want to have kids kids are pretty
resilient i mean my mom abandoned us and my
dad was never around and i turned out okay
okay might be tread carefully bit of an
understatement because you're perfect
okay there it is that's what i was
going to say the whole time yeah
get back oh back
it's freaking out i'll call john
henry he won't be able to stop it whoa
oh no
michael chiklis
it's collaboration
irons do you copy irons i can't get him to wake
up wake up fire rhythms indicate he's unconscious
only now
wow holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] damn damn damn oh crap
it's like watching the
injustice game that is awesome
damn got that hbo money
oh ain't doing [ __ ] come on man
he must just absorb all that power
that's not doomsday
that's him
that's gotta be bizarro oh
my nipple just got so hard
yo they like straight up cloned
him you won't like this clark
but i gotta call anderson sam no there's
a bizarre version of superman on the
you're not superman your suit can break you can
get hurt i know why are you doing this because
they need my help i don't want you out there
again not until we do something about this suit
so you got to fix that thing up busters
are completely shot cpu needs spirit
that's awesome this is going to be the
best bonding experience of your lives
what am i even going gonna say to her babe
i haven't seen her in years just be honest
tell her that you've missed her she's still
your sister lois no matter what luzaro
so go ahead ask me anything
ask me about smallville
ask me about my aunt jenny's marinara
sauce that my daughter's obsessed with
hey your dad said i could come in yeah did you
tell you not to run away scared this time yeah
he did um oh it's kind of intense i almost
ran away so is this gonna be a good talk
or a bad talk i think you should open this first
will you marry me oh my god thank god
my grandfather gave to her back when they
were in high school when he knew we wanted
and you're giving it to me yes because i
love you sarah you want to stay together yes
for a really long time
does that mean jordan gets to kiss someone
yeah you could go one hop last night use it
wisely jordan john so i had a little chat with
timmy today about where he gets his drugs from
i would like to buy some if you're here to dump
me just do it okay for the record this that's why
i didn't tell you in the first place okay i knew
you wouldn't understand i think your joke is gonna
turn true i've been worried about this whole time
and i'm not here to convince you to stop selling
you're not no i just i need you to sell
something to me damn it man not like this
crap hello lois lucy isn't coming
yep lucy's been reeled back in she thought
it would be better if i came instead
it's like a [ __ ] fincher movie adventure
movie color palette the angles the lenses whoo
damn that's crazy
wow
oh damn oh yes your first bizarro title
oh nice that's cool ah i'm glad the show's still
good yeah that was amazing best episode yet
that was that was uh that was a really great stuff
this is actually genuinely genuinely a really good
like great episode and it's really pulled in it
was like nobody said something in episode two
about just it not feeling like it was like
soaring and like yeah like locked in great
on its stride but you know still really good yeah
this was like pretty much from beginning to end
was like oh no this is his life we're locked in
this was the show i missed it yeah absolutely 100
all right cool let's chit chat yeah my memory
of bizarro's not like the the the strong my my
introduction of bizarro must have been the 90s
superman i have a very specific memory of like
clones of clark and then he sees like uh dudes
clark save their superman save low saying he's
like super bad save loads or something and and
then uh there's like you know bizarre has been
i think he was actually introduced in super boy
if i'm not mistaken okay yeah oh and there's
been talks about like maybe jordan becomes a
super boy so it's just it in a way it's cool
to get that and and and there are clues like
it didn't make it wasn't quite clicking with me
of like why would doomsday just sort of be down
there i'm not with no prior fanfare or or yeah
like personal lead up to how he was formed yeah
yeah yeah so um it was like it seems like they're
doing doomsday and they keep saying doomsday and
so they were obviously trying to mislead and then
you know when thinking about the gloves too at
the time of filming i couldn't find any photos
that resembled it but then eventually yeah i think
in like earlier renditions sometimes he would have
suits with the gloves so i think like everything
was about misdirecting god but then with the
knowing what the dod is doing and then you know uh
like the amount of duplication of powers and stuff
yeah like there's a it's not far-fetched
they've got to a point where they could finally
clone superman but he's basically like a messed
up clone version of calo yeah i think i think
his power set can be a little bit if i'm not
mistaken i think it's a little bit like opposite
effect what it can do i think instead of like
heat ray vision it's like freeze ray vision okay
or is it hot that's how i think
it's hot right yeah hot breath
and i think like you can only see through lead but
can't actually create anything else oh yeah but
there's like a bunch of different versions of him
like sometimes he's just like like unintelligible
zombie version and then there are versions of
him that are intelligible and it seems like
you know starting him off here that they're gonna
i imagine they would develop him to be a character
who was like i'm a little bit more zombified
yeah then eventually grows into into a more
uh fully formed uh yeah character motivation or at
least some kind of way we can dramatically connect
and have an actual internal conflict between
him and clark in some ways i might be way off
base here i've always sort of viewed bizarro
as like uh if solomon grundy was a clone of
this is this is getting us one step closer
to maybe having a solomon grudy at some point
true on this show but no yeah i i wasn't he didn't
uh bizarro superman figure heavily into the like
apocalypse animated uh it was like a justice
league uh that was recent i i got i get the
mixed up uh on the names but you know like he had
taken over and it was one of the more recent like
animated movies that had a horror tone to it and
uh and it was you know kind of in in line with uh
when the snyder cut was like dropping or whatever
but um i don't know i appreciate that maybe i've
seen it so much i the topic it was kind of a blur
to me there's there's one in which yeah like you
know like dark side wins or something like that
and then bizarro superman's in charge and uh
and yeah like yeah i've seen that i don't
really remember but maybe right but yeah
like i don't know that was probably the last
time i saw him in animated form but uh it get
it got me really excited to hear partly because of
just all the like horror move like they've put in
these really effective horror movie flourishes
both with like the crazy freakouts and things
but also just in the timing of when they put in
these attacks or especially in this episode really
kind of making it feel sort of like a alma like
it it almost reminded me of like a 70s possession
movie but with more of a crazy modern like
james oneish sensibility of like yeah when you
are like in james won movie a james bond movie
i could have got there much more efficiently if
i just said that uh yeah but that like when he
yeah has that freak out and he has to like clear
the the you know pent up heat vision into his
hands like is really gripping and jarring and
unnerving and to have that coming out
of clark at the same time as yeah this
sort of nightmare version of him is emerging
it feels like a really significant character
to kind of throw in like right at season two but
uh like i love the way that they're making these
personal to superman without having it feel
too like silly or wrote or cliche about it
yeah because i think the one thing with
superman is like there's a lot of us to
make superman interesting it seems like something
that other people often default to is like dark
superman yeah and and i think what they did clever
here was what happens when he can't control his
rage on his family yeah which is like the scariest
thought of them all yeah like he can he he has the
capability of just murdering his children and he
doesn't even he gets so blindsided by his rage
it's like sometimes a rage could i like the
metaphor of that because sometimes rage you feel
like a blackout moment for people and like when
he was talking with lois about what happened with
jordan you know i'm sure there's like
more sci-fi [ __ ] going on in his head
but the correlation of i don't even remember what
the conversation was really about i've heard that
happen with people like serious rage issues is
that they just can't even recollect the details
of what happened in in the blowout moment uh so
yeah it was scary and the way they built that
were because like you know with jordan at least
it's like well george probably took a hit but
i want to be good
jonathan alone in the locker and then like
to me that was even scarier because yeah
like oh dude that guy has no powers yeah yeah
he can't withstand the laser blast right now
and uh yeah watching him just be like a father
on the verge of committing just domestic violence
possibly immersion is a scary concept and then
um you know what that must be for the children
to have to be on the receiving end of that
i think is a bold ass move yeah absolutely and
it's funny to like to talk about sometimes i feel
like people like give up on on us when it comes to
criticizing something because you know we had that
or like questioning something because we had that
thing about the whole plot with the cult yeah and
and uh you know like this kind of feels like
it came out of nowhere yeah and like all right
but then it became like vastly more interesting
oh yeah and proportions are way more on in this
episode for that story especially and now
that it is becoming so much more personal
to lois and it's really revealing and they brought
her dad back in yeah and you're actually you know
seeing the presence of this cult leader character
whether ali alliston uh like actually you know
stepping into first just on tv and then into the
actual narrative of the show like you know yeah
they made those moments really hit and i think
it's funny like having it be about yeah cult and
true crime podcasts like i liked that they then
accented that with some little finchery flourishes
to really pull you into the kind of different
sort of psychological nightmare of that sure yeah
yeah that's a good point because there's a
lot of nightmarishness about this whole thing
everyone's like really anguished and now jordan's
gonna have a drug jonathan's gonna have a drug
problem he wants to be like pop yeah yeah it's
it's about time jordan uh jonathan did something
yeah that was really cool like overly questionable
about it because it makes sense you know like what
the horse he did last season like get a little
drunk yeah and like get a little mad but but
he's been the best boy the whole oh yeah he's
getting his mvp for the heart of the show just
like he's always is so understanding the guys
guys pushing through a corner now man yeah he's
getting surrounded but he's in enough at home he's
his brother and his dad have the greatest powers
of all time and then at school his girlfriend is
like going behind his back and then he can't play
because the guys do interesting it just makes
sense that eventually he's gonna do something
else you know not he can't be perfect so yeah
i want to see how that progresses of course um
but the like who plays lois lane again why am i
busy she is just so like she is she is fantastic
like tyler is absolutely perfect in this role too
i just think that her performance across the board
the just due to the fact of how her her
portrayal lois lane has to carry so much trauma
and doesn't like play it in a way that is um like
look at me traumatized you know yeah yeah yeah
it's not acting pills yeah i think i think
her performance is so great yeah like
constantly is is like every detail of her for
portrayal is perfect and it's it is cool to
like get these stories of like here's what clark
is dealing with here's what lois is dealing with
and then they have that moment on the porch where
they become like lovey-dovey with each other and
dear you like oh yeah this is the the partnership
that's so good like this this is just such a great
like package yeah of a series and then you have um
john and natalie and the bar like i love the way
that scene was actually yeah because i was like
here we go yeah here we go they seem to have a
really sharp awareness for those kinds of things
because they have really conscientiously timed
both those those plot lines that could become
very tedious like natalie being upset at the
circumstances surrounding lois and john and and
like jordan and sarah like all that but they've
really conscientiously timed those things out too
then in moments like this make you go oh god oh
nice yeah yeah like the way the flip of the
dialogue started happening like i don't want
you going out there again my mind immediately
went to ah how long's the scene gonna go like
i can't do the scenes connect it's necessary
yeah but it's like in the mind that the wheels
just start turning of like we know that eventually
she's gonna have to get on board with this stuff
let's like drag this out yeah you're good
at not spinning your wheels don't start no
we need to have this conversation and then
immediately to just like a line or two later
to go like not until the suit is back like oh
[ __ ] that is so like great because i think
all of us were probably in that boat they keep
does they set you up for her to just be like
yeah and she's always so uh you're like
why is my dad out there she watches
the suit fly off and this is worry concern oh and
the [ __ ] action was great too yeah yeah like
they really do get that hp money on this show
because yeah like they make especially the the
fight that ensues between superman and bizarro
like and and the lead up to that with just
all the soldiers like they really made that
stuff scary and it hit hard like all the hits
felt harsh in a way where i forgot that this
was again i feel like i feel like cw shows
are cursed with the compliment of when they're
particularly good you forget that they're seen
and that was absolutely something that
that happened here i had that one shot
in the air yeah oh that is some of the best like
flying characters in flight fighting each other
like in sky is can so often go hard to do
so terribly wrong like it you some more
often than not it just looks awful it's like
a terrible green screen which way are we going
and that looked great and it's like broad daylight
yeah and i was so impressed with uh the way they
i was really really impressed with the way they
handled that uh just that one little moment it was
like watching like the injustice game and the way
that's realized yeah um so yeah because there's
not like masking it with overshadowing it yeah it
makes it hard to see yeah it can feel more real
or just like let's have them just crashing into
buildings yeah look it looked really really great
you know especially for a tv show um because that
was movie quality you know it's like i think i
think zack snyder's man of steel uh the the fight
in smallville is is like my favorite superman
fight ever uh but the that to see on a tv show and
be like damn that's like flight fighting yeah like
that because they don't do that much in the in
that in that fight scene there that's pretty much
on the ground yeah they're like up in the sky
you know it's just yeah i don't know how it was
i was so impressed with that moment it's
transportive and cinematic in a way that
you're not entirely yeah in a way that's in some
way almost unexpected but that i think is a really
thing it's something that's really magical about
this show is that you have those elements they're
really plugged in there's not always action but
when there is it's really kind of accentuated to
the 10th degree as much as it can be and then
you have great character stories and you know
it's like this could all feel kind of like a
soap opera and yet somehow it doesn't really
no i was kind of getting soap opera vibes in
like the second episode yeah yeah and i feel
like they they've come back up to like okay these
are just you know like these human struggles that
intervene while also crazy science fiction and
also cult crime stuff is happening uh and and
we had a lana running for mayor that's that's
oh yeah yeah i'm figuring that out oh yeah yeah
there's so many plot lines in here i know it's
so much fun and yeah it doesn't it didn't feel
overloaded and nothing felt like it was too short
except that we didn't get to see them play madden
that's true that is true seeing
them play map uh yeah i like the um
i just think the way to handle bizarro is so good
like it i it just seemed like it must have been
bizarro with the because they're obviously
setting them up for a big villain right yeah
and i was like it's visaro and then he
went away i'm like uh [ __ ] do i have
to cut that out of the video because it's
actually blue superman it's just a clone
but then to go to the fortress of solitude yeah
and then he's looking upon it he's got the cape
it's like yeah you're like okay that's
the that's the confirmation yeah
i think that's correct 100 that's so cool well
that's the thing is like i i love that it's
like the first season you have yeah that
that pitch of you know you've got morgan
ed who's kind of uh taro who's kind of like
an inversion of superman in an ideological
sense for him to butt up against with and
now it's gonna be in the most physical sense
you know oh but back to what you were bringing
up with um her running for mayor and all that
i think she should have prepared for that question
well i think you have to do like what i learned
it's classic debate if you're running for
politicians you know like i used to go on like
screen junkies movie fights and the number one
thing i have to factor in when i'm playing that
game is what can they use against me and how can
i counter this or how can i defend myself you
know yeah like that's the number one point of
like i think especially if you're running for
politics absolutely you gotta first think people
are gonna come at you of what's everything people
can attack me on or question me on and you gotta
have that really thought out like you gotta map
that on like that question that was brought up
like i don't really feel like you should
have thought of i have some arena of this
yeah morgan edge wasn't that long ago and that's
something that at least like for forget those
mortgages yeah like you know absolutely and then
also too then to wrap it around at the end i i
really liked the moment between her and sarah
where they're figuring out a new way to do the
campaign although and i'm sure it'll evolve as
the show moves on but but in that moment i was
also thinking this doesn't exactly seem like
something that will immediately counteract the
events of earlier today because like it's much
more like you know it's it's more personal and
fun than it is sort of like no i'm back and i'm
prepared uh but that's just like a tiny little
i don't know knit no i i got you like it was
like a cute moment but at the same time when
i was watching it i was like but she's gonna she
might get you're being recorded now yeah so you
might get questions here that might stump you
yeah and you might get comments that are pretty
vile yeah like is that dude from earlier gonna
see this video and be like oh no you're a person
you're cool you know i forget about my question
and my farm that i lost yeah yeah yeah yeah um
trust me there's people who've done live streams
yeah you really need to be like oh [ __ ] people
immediately and and i don't know like especially
yeah it seems like people are apt to jump in and
really derail you if you're in politics especially
um immediately especially if you're in politics
and then you have a past that might that could be
questioned people will jump in and attack you yeah
and they like to do it in a live setting yeah
yeah oh yeah those uh god what are those called
uh conference what kind of conference calls were
those called again town halls town hall yeah yeah
um yeah so that was kind of the yeah i don't know
but the the moments with sarah were nice there's
i like the character i like that they do the
gray area with with that you know yeah like she
i don't talk at all about that girl all right i
do hey you know i i like the way that they played
that because it was sort of like i don't know
if that's my thing maybe but yeah it happened
and uh i'm not ashamed i thought she was talking
about cheating then well i guess that's probably
the root of it but i feel like it's it's i feel
like the thing is it's harder for me to look at
that as just simply cheating because it is sort
of like a discovery moment of another variety
on top of you kissed somebody so in that sense i
i maybe that's just me kind of projecting that on
to it but i kind of took it in both because like
the the cheating yeah i'm like i feel like you
that i would be i would be ashamed of
that but it's good that you were honest
about it whereas like oh i kissed somebody who i
didn't think i would normally kiss that i wouldn't
feel the need to be ashamed of it yeah oh yeah of
course not to be ashamed of that yeah the um but
of cheating in general there's a better argument
to be made for why you might feel a little bit
i don't know really don't feel better and then
to the person she gets like well it didn't mean
anything i mean that's a bummer meaningless
kiss was the one that caused all this promise i
would want it to be at least important which
which it does seem like in a human context
but yeah um but i'm glad i i love the human
part of him being in love and what i'm thinking
because i know that's when you're like a
teenager in love and you're like this is it
yeah because it's like it's so it's so like uh so
grossing yeah it's like such a new feeling you're
consumed with this other person yeah that first
like heartbreak i don't think you ever forget that
first like a real heartbreak that unique feeling
of having your soul ripped like that but it feels
like so literal when you literally feel like
you've been dr strange punched out of your head
yeah yeah she's just floating in there walking
around with the heart that's empty yeah yeah so um
yeah i i i really like that humanism like jordan
your wants are gonna change like i think that was
that was so real yeah it feels like for all ages
it is because yeah they didn't talk down to that
position that jordan's in which i feel like you
know for adult writers is probably a pitfall that
is harder to avoid sometimes to really make that
feel natural and to not make it feel like well
obviously dudes like you know he doesn't have
the perspective yet it gave it the credence
and and the sort of tenderness that yeah just
like every perspective is given it's you know
it's uh yeah it's credence guys cher
knocked it out of the park what can i say
perfect what more is that a saying it's
amazing guys leave your thoughts down below
is everyone shout out um we got up some more
patrons to shout out if you want to shout out
some more patrons from our from our special
shout out here yeah why not kathleen maher
kiss me mr crispy chris bostin be thrust
in clifford the big red dog rodriguez
sacks the crooked captain hook jaren
wanner bananer yale ferguson person
nick x-ray specs rosalie taylor the
valor bear in the garage also a lodge
phil leiter the weisser william bryant the fire
hydrant kusi kusi lucifushi ericons 3969 matt i
use some more audio than the rodeos shaquita
bonito washington logan burton b flirtin zack
hershberger with extra onions ricardo martinez
zombie shin on needles and pins i think that's
what your name is we think we did google we did
it we we did our best dude yeah comment below and
tell us what your name is we went through the the
uh very we traveled on horseback riding library
cross-referencing ancient tomes
i think these two characters line
uh yeah all right guys americans thank you so much
for um being here yes support means a lot catching